♪ Four and three and two and one
- What's up guys?
I'm Matt FX and this is
the Broad City music recap
for episode six, Stolen Phone.
Stolen Phone starts with
a cold open by Obeycity,
A kingpin of the local
Brooklyn music scene.
Obeycity is Sam Obey,
founder of the adventurously
cosmic label Astro Nautico.
He's personally
signed to LuckyMe,
the label started by Scottish
producer Hudson Mohawke,
who you'll know as
one of the main sounds
of Kanye West's most
recent record, Yeezus.
Obeycity's track Intrique
runs under Abby and Ilana's
late night Facebook booty hunt.
It picks up kinda half
way through the track,
which is really good
as the cut starts
speeding up while they're
going through guys names.
- I feel like I'm
on coke right now!
(yelling)
PJ Mallory.
- Bobby Kornhauser.
- Johnny Fiessinger.
- Benny McKaro.
- Ryan Long.
- Rod White.
- We are like feminist
heroes right now!
(notifications blinging)
(yelling)
- Next up we have
Philly act, Damn Right
setting the scene at
the bar in Stolen Phone.
Damn Right features producer
and vocalist Johnny Fiessinger,
a personal friend of Abby's
from way back in the day,
so we were really
excited to be able
to include Halo in the episode.
(Techno music)
- I'm from Philly.
Philadelphia.
When I was five I was actually
an extra in the
movie Philadelphia.
It filmed right near
my dad's office,
so, I learned about AIDS
before a lot of my friends.
- It's a really wonderful track
and it's got the perfect
tone to set the scene
for a night of hitting
on guys at the bar.
Shout out to Swine
in the West Village
for being the bar we
filmed at by the way,
you guys are dope.
Lastly, I wanna
highlight another track
from the bar scene,
Annika Zee's Make it Right.
Make it Right plays
underneath Abby's
honest and cute flirtation
scene with the guy at the bar,
and again, sets the perfect
tone for the emotion at hand.
- Cell phones are so
close to being perfect
except that I just miss,
like, there's like a
dial tone.
- Dial tone!
- Yes! Are you kidding me?
- No. Yeah.
- You're trying to make
a connection with someone
and there's no sound
anymore, it's just like,
hi, you're there.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's needed.
- Annika's a student at the
Clive Davis
Institute in New York
and I met her a couple
years back at a house party.
It's been really, really
cool watching her progress
as both a producer
and a vocalist.
She's got a full EP coming
out later this year,
so keep an eye out for that.
And that was the music recap
for Broad City's episode six,
entitled Stolen Phone.
I'm Matt FX,
you can follow me on
Twitter at Mattfxfxfxfx.
Also follow Broad City on
Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr
for more posts about music and
other stuff about the show.
Just wanted to mention,
there isn't gonna be
a recap for next week
as our girls get
trapped in a hurricane
with no electricity or music,
but, I'll see you guys
in a couple weeks.